We've got a story about some relics
that just unearthed in the UK.
"Newsweek" reports a mom and daughter in Lincolnshire
were picking up the litter at a local river
when they found a message in a bottle.
Two messages, actually.
Oh my gosh.
From teens, Jennifer and Janet,
who were looking for boyfriends back in the summer of 1966.
Wow.
Their notes are fully intact.
Janet wrote, "I am 15, not bad looking.
Long, wavy, brown chestnut hair
and five foot four.
So they made the first old dating app, Rossi.
If you think about it.
(audience laugh)
I guess that's cute.
Yeah, okay.
Okay, it's cute.
(audience laugh)
I dunno, it's so romantic putting a message in the bottle
and it's littering.
(audience laugh)
Right, it's littering.
(audience applauding)
Threw that bottle into the ocean.
Well.
I think it's cute though.
And we actually looked into this story
and one of the women they tracked down,
and it turns out she found love.
What?
Yeah, she's married.
Not because of the bottle,
just like, in life it worked out.
And I love that people put out into the world
what they want.
You know, she did that.
And we've talked about you online dating.
You are on it, you're off it sometimes.
What about this?
You wanna kick it old school?
Cause' I have a bottle right here.
(audience laugh)
I can write it down if you wanna.
You wanna write or you want me to do it?
Oh, I want you to write it.
Cause I feel like going through your energy like,
we're doubling down on the goodness.
Hello, I'm drew.
(audience laugh)
I'm, what do you wanna say about yourself?
I'm-
Stunning.
(audience applauding)
Someone in the audience said "Stunning".
That's a good move.
Can I write it?
I love you.
And what's your name?
Nicole.
I'm putting you in the note.
(audience laugh)
Nicole said-
Hardworking and capable.
Hardworking.
And a wonderful mom.
(audience applauding)
My glasses fogged up.
I wrote, "Hello, I'm Drew.
I'm stunning, according to Nicole.
She also said I'm hard working and capable.
Nicole talks too fast.
(audience laugh)
By the way, recycle."
Okay.
(audience applauding)
And I'm gonna put this in your bottle.
It's all done.
Can I give this to her?
(audience applauding)
Here.
So here, I just wrote this little love note for you.
(audience applauding)
"I heart Nicole, love Drew."
Here you go.
Oh my gosh, thank you.
You're welcome.
(audience applauding)
Thank you so much.
Keep them, you're good at that.
Good job.
Oh, I was not expecting that, Nicole.
I wasn't expecting this either, but I'm so happy.
Thank you.
Wow, God.
Okay, well.
Next up, CNN reports that music icon, Dolly Parton
says that there's only one person
that she would want to play her in a movie.
And it's none other than Tony award-winning,
Broadway powerhouse, Kristin Chenoweth.
Such a great-
(audience applauding)
This makes so much sense.
She says Kristin is absolutely fantastic
and if there's ever a biopic, she would be her first choice.
I mean, Rossi.
It's a no brainer, but I can...
(audience applauding)
I do wanna say.
Rossi, why am I going parliament
and you're going Dolly Parton.
I look like I'm a judge in a British show.
(audience laugh)
Give me a gavel.
What is going on?
You do.
I don't know, but I am feeling myself in this Dolly.
♪ I tumble out of bed and stumbled to the kitchen. ♪
Look at me.
♪ Pour myself a cup ♪
of ambition.
♪ A cup of ambition. ♪
Watch out Kristin Chenoweth, I'm coming for you gig.
And I am going to change legislation.
(upbeat music)